the only one more excited for this day
to come than me has got to be Intel they
have been hard at work on their Arc
series dedicated gpus since at least
2017 when they hired Raja kaduri from
AMD who was leading up their Radeon
graphics Division and it's finally
freaking here this is their Alchemist
code name first generation Arc Flagship
the
a770 and
it comes with important safety and
regulatory information
Nate let's play indeed it's a cute case
badge
holy crap this is it
You Gotta Give Them full credit it looks
flipping sick hold on this plugs into a
USB header and this is going to handle
the RGB Lighting on your graphics card
that's right a reference card with RGB
is this
international power plugs
is this seriously a stand for the card
is that what it is is it a stick
oh oh I see why does it come with two
bases wait shut up that's their solution
to be able to wall mount it
or wall mount it this way
is to have two completely separate bases
with the power switch in a different
spot
[Music]
yeah I couldn't engineer a better
solution but you know what fine oh fatal
flaw we got the top down camera and I
have no way of showing it to the top
wait
a solution
now the performance embargo hasn't
lifted yet but we can talk about all the
detailed specs and Intel has released
enough performance information about
this GPU that we can make some pretty
educated guesses first the basics though
the arc lineup is divided up into three
five and seven series products just like
you would see on their desktop CPUs so
this being an a770 makes it the top
performer of their top series it uses
their dg2 512 processor clocked at 2.1
gigahertz that means it has 32 of their
XE cores and 32 Ray tracing units it's
equipped with 8 or 16 gigabytes of video
memory that's what makes this the
limited edition it has 16 gigs of memory
and that's connected via a 256-bit bus
and it's rated to draw 225 watts of
power which is our first red flag
because Intel says that this card is
designed to compete against nvidia's RTX
3060 and amd's Radeon that's
6650xt both of which draw in the
neighborhood of 160 to 170 Watts also
neither of which use a 256-bit memory
bus that means that especially once we
dig in a little deeper and find the
transistor count of this card that intel
was hoping for better performance out of
this GPU more along the lines of a 3070
or a 6700 glass card making matters more
complicated for Intel Nvidia has already
announced their RTX 40 series of cards
however nvidia's pricing is so far out
to lunch that if at the price Intel has
announced which is 330 dollars for this
card they do manage to be competitive
with a 30 60 30 60 TI and if the
overclocking Headroom is anywhere near
what they've talked about
Ark could actually end up being pretty
competitive I guess we should take a
closer look at the card man did they
ever nail the Aesthetics you've got a
diffused RGB strip down here
diffused RGB lighting around both of the
fans meant in real life once it's lit it
looks amazing oh do you have a test
bench for me right there Bell Events has
got a test bench for me hey thank you so
welcome
all right let's just uh yeah what could
go wrong uh that could go wrong one
thing to note is that probably because
it was intended to come out a lot sooner
the art series does not use any of the
new funky pcie power connectors it just
has a standard eight pin plus six pin oh
and that USB is right here is that what
that USB connector is for
I don't remember them telling me that it
was for RGB but like you're connected
via pcie can you just do it that way
can't wait to show this to you guys oh
after this message from our sponsor
thanks to iFixit for sponsoring today's
video iFixit wants to help you skip your
next phone upgrade helping you save
money if your battery life sucks put in
a new battery if your screen is broken
replace it using one of ifixit's fix
kits starting at just 10.99 USD you can
repair everything from camera lenses to
screens batteries and more and their
step-by-step guides are designed to help
you along the way with photos and
detailed instructions you can visit the
link in the video description to find
the repair kit that's right for your
phone
okay there we go does that look awesome
or what of course there's more to a GPU
than just looks starting with is it even
gonna fit in your case so we grabbed a
couple of objects that we can compare
our a772 starting of course with our
classic short circuit banana for scale
and a little something like that
lttstore.com but also some more useful
things
for context here is a 3080 TI this is
the top tier Flagship level card
it's pretty big isn't almost as big as a
3080 TI
um here's a 36 DTI this is more along
the lines of the kind of Founders
Edition card that you might be competing
with in terms of performance it's a
little on the long boy side here's our
6700 XT which is actually okay higher
tier card than this one's about the same
size which again would give you some
idea of what intel was actually
targeting and you can see this in some
of the other specs as well when we
compared the raw pixel rate and texture
rate memory bandwidth with something
like a 3060 TI the a770 kinda craps all
over it but because Intel is kind of new
to the driver game when it comes to high
performance dedicated gpus
it's speculated that aside from any
architectural oversights there might
have been on a first-gen product they
have a lot to learn especially when it
comes to optimizing for older especially
DirectX 9 and earlier titles and you
can't not support them because that's
part of the beauty of PC gaming is that
you've got this incredible back catalog
of games that you can go back and play
even on Modern Hardware that sometimes
does little bit of hackery in spite of
all the delays one reassuringly modern
thing about this card is its feature set
Intel is claiming that right out of the
gate they're going to have Ray tracing
performance that is up to 65 percent
stronger Peak compared to their Rivals
the up to Peak that's a lot of
qualifications but hey at least they're
going to support Ray tracing right out
of the gate and they're going to have
support for XE super sampling xcss which
is a competitor to nvidia's deep
learning super sampling and amd's
Fidelity effects super resolution using
AI to boost frame rates at higher
resolutions how well it works though it
remains to be seen and based on how much
work Nvidia and AMD have already put
into this technology I would say Intel
is going to be playing catch-up where
they won't be playing catch-up is in
their display interfaces on the back
here we're going to find HDMI 2.1 so
you'll be able to do up to 4K
120 hertz or 8K 60 I believe you can do
on HDMI 2.1 and this is where things get
really cool this is our first Hands-On
with DisplayPort 2.0 however
unlike previous version of DisplayPort
DP 2.0 is not just a cut and dried
here's what you get it's divided up into
ultra high bitrate uhbr 10 13.5 I think
and 20. and what those numbers mean is
the data rate times four so these are DP
2.0 uhbr 10 for a total of 40 gigabit
per second ports okay it's a little
confusing kind of which it was just
uhbr40 so that that would be a little
more intuitive for normies but in a
world where USB naming conventions exist
I guess this is a win
another win and another modern feature
is Intel support for av1 encoding and
not on this GPU but we have actually
played around with it a fair bit in the
last week on Intel arc on the A380 and
it's pretty freaking cool at 3 500
kilobit per second our encoded game
streaming footage looks about the same
as nvidia's nvank at 6 000 kilobit per
second so what this means is that once
platforms like twitch support it you can
expect to be able to stream at the same
quality that people can today on a much
lesser internet connection or you can
expect to see better quality twitch
streams pretty cool for all my
positivity though and as much as I would
love for there to be a valid third
competitor in the dedicated graphics
card space
I do have to temper my enthusiasm a
little bit because Intel is up against a
lot of obstacles they've got to figure
out that backwards compatibility game
performance they've got to compete with
AMD and Nvidia both releasing new series
of gpus when Arc Alchemist was really
supposed to be competing with the last
series of gpus and another big one is
that we talk about second-hand gpus a
lot and given the recent crypto crash
there's a lot of them out there at very
aggressive pricing and the reality of it
is that Intel doesn't have any used gpus
and they certainly don't benefit from
selling them so it's going to be an
extremely competitive market they seem
pretty confident in their 329 pricing
and I certainly wish them luck but hey
if that doesn't work out for them then
it can only be a win for gamers because
they've made them so now they definitely
have to sell them just like I'm gonna
sell you uh that you should go subscribe
to LTT while you're subscribing to Short
Circuit so you don't miss our full
review view of this and other Arc
Alchemist cards